welcome back to the games with stage
here at e3 2017 joining myself and Peter
brown is David day from Bungie here to
talk about destiny - hi Darren great
thanks for having me
thanks for joining us I mean so destiny
- is like the big reveal everyone's
looking forward to this quarter know
next quarter depending on what number
September yes um I mean how does it feel
to finally obviously been development
for a while how does it feel to have
footage out there people finally
starting to play the game obviously we
love it the energy on the show floor
here is wonderful we have people who are
lining up to play in the crucible or to
go on a strike or even to play the first
story mission in the game so we are
welcoming thousands of people to take
their first step in the world of destiny
- there are so many talented people that
I work with at Bungie and their focus is
on creating amazing worlds that bring
players together and introducing them to
heroes that will lead them on the way to
protect humanity and when we can expose
that work to the people in our community
or new players who have never tried a
Bungie game before and we can you know
sort of drink deep of their excitement
and their enthusiasm that what that's
what makes the hard work all worth it
that's why we come into work every day
is to create experiences that will
capture their imagination and blow their
mind and make them feel like a badass
and then hopefully introduce them to
friends that they can enjoy the game
with I suppose I mean like a specific
community that this will be the first
chance they can really jump into this
neat is the PC crowd yes is it it's
finally nice to sort of be able to get
everyone on board we have heard so much
feedback from PC gamers that they would
love to see destiny too on PC either
because they're playing the game already
and they want to embrace it on their
favorite platform or because they're on
the PC and that's the only place they
play games and they took a look at the
player experience they took a look at
the cooperative activities or you know
the deep options for customization or
just the community that we've been able
to foster around this game and they
wanted to join that community they
wanted to play that game so the
opportunity to welcome them into the
Destiny community is something that I
can't wait for as a community
Gai as somebody who makes that my sole
focus being able to welcome a new
segment an entire new frontier into our
community is awesome I'm sure they'll
bring in their own unique perspectives
we're going to learn all about this game
that we created all over again from a
different viewpoint and we will grow and
evolve that experience based on what
they tell us as we always have so as a
sequel you know I think people looked at
the original destiny and saw it expanded
upon a few times and they sort of viewed
it as a platform in a sense destiny to
is doing a lot of things differently but
what is the one thing that really you
know draws a line in the sand like this
is a sequel it's not just sort of more
the same I mean I know there's a
emphasis on lore now like story being
more of a prominent thing but in the
eyes of your team what really sets us
apart from the original desks well like
you said we're telling a brand new story
we are raising the stakes
at the last safe city on earth is not so
safe anymore
it comes under attack very much by
surprise a brand new enemy from the
Cabal Empire you know the tip of the
spear of their professional military
brings everything that they had to bear
against the city
so the first mission of the game finds
people fighting to protect a place that
has always been a serene environment at
the center of the game the place where
players have come together to acquire
new weapons or to trade in you know
their engrams for new armor and to
upgrade their characters and now that
shelter and supply is now in flames and
is being attacked by enemies that are
bigger and badder than anything they've
ever faced before we're sending them out
to for new worlds to explore and
exploring those worlds is going to be a
lot more fun they'll be able to stay in
that world they'll be able to move from
activity to activity they'll be able to
plunder it for its secrets and very near
and dear to my heart we are investing
deeply in the way players share this
experience together there will be client
support in the game there will be new
ways for players that don't have a
friends list that is bristling with
willing allies to reach out and to say I
would like to experience the most
challenging activities that this game
has to offer I would like to play a raid
I would like to master the end game but
I don't have people to play with and
destiny is going to do a lot better job
of exposing them to the clans that
we'll bring them along on just one
activity and if that goes well they can
receive an invitation to join those
clans right there in the game but if
you're a solo player if being part of a
group in the game and and sort of living
up to their expectations for you is not
the way you play they will always be
available to you as your guide to lead
you through to the mountaintop if you
will and to tackle a raid boss or to
play a nightfall strike or to even go
into the crucible during its most
challenging and exciting moments how can
you um not controls maybe not the word
but how do you kind of prepare for
there's always going to be griefers
right sure how can you sort of ensure
that I like maybe these solo players are
bit nervous about playing with other
people how can you ensure that they're
going to be playing with the people who
will show them like lead them by the
hand in the right way absolutely we've
thought a lot about this Bungie has a
lot of experience in building games that
create community and to foster those
types of social bonds and friendship so
we think a lot about how can we create a
cooperative experience that still gives
players control over the quality of
their gameplay so the voices that you
hear in destiny are the ones that you
invite to be members of your fireteam so
if you want to embark on a cooperative
activity with other players you invite
them to be on your team you can then
talk to those players but there are
other social moments of the game like
public events or the people that you
cross paths with on your basic
exploration of these worlds and those
are people you play with those are
people that you combine your gunfire
with to overcome these obstacles but you
don't don't necessarily have to hear
what they have to say with the new
guided games feature they'll be able to
browse a directory of clans that are
inviting solo players to join them for a
mission you'll have a sense of what
their client name is what their motto is
you'll be able to jump into a pregame
lobby and exchange some words with those
players to see if they're the types of
people that you'd like to keep the
company of for the next hour or two or
however long it takes to complete that
activity we always provide community
interaction but it's very much opt-in in
destiny so you're never confronted by it
you're never assaulted by it and if it's
something that you don't
want to have part of your experience you
can still enjoy so much of what this has
game has to offer exploring the worlds
uncovering its secrets playing through
the story missions as a lone wolf as we
say in the first game sort of the story
was kind of eked out through like
grimoire cards that you had to sort of
find unlock and check out online and
then you had the taken King that kind of
gave it a whole new personality and gave
and that's I mean because when I laugh I
laughs and then I got the taking he and
I came back because it was that story
that latched me onto the world I guess
here it's that much more of a focus in
destiny to I want to have that from the
get-go
absolutely and that was when we first
introduced players to destiny - it was
giving them a glimpse into the character
driven story
it was reacquainting them with the
vanguard it was having commander Zavala
talk about what makes a guardian a
guardian and we're telling a bigger
story than players of destiny have ever
seen it's got more story missions it's
got more cinematics takes you to four
strange new worlds that have different
mysteries to uncover and ways to really
enjoy the story inside the game and that
was a huge creative pillar for us that
was a goal that directed every decision
that we made about storytelling and
destiny is that you should never have to
drop your controller and reach for your
smartphone or open your laptop to
understand the story we were telling it
will come right at you in the game it
will play out in the cutscenes that add
flavor to the missions it will be things
that you discover in the world and it
will be the characters that you meet
along the way with different types of
adventures and different types of
activities that will help you understand
the places where you find yourself and
you know the the moments in the
realities that shape that player
experience so a lot of investment in
NPCs and those sort of things to flesh
out the world yes that's the idea is
that you'll you know you'll put your
boots on the ground of a planet that
you've never been to before and you will
find people in those destinations who
have missions for you to undertake and
have things for you to do and as you do
those things you'll be earning rewards
from them that make your character more
powerful but you'll also understand a
little bit more about what are these
places that you've journeyed to and what
shaped these landscapes and what's at
stake in this game
do these NPCs evolve over time like are
they persistent based on you know how
you interact with them and maybe the
things you help them do there'll be
people that you find in the world and
there will be the ones that give you
your marching orders okay now I guess
that you've kind of left the Xbox 360
and the PlayStation 3 behind what is
that enabled you guys to do for destiny
to its own abled us to create even
larger spaces for you to play them
you're going to find more people
fighting by your side you're going to
find more enemies up on the screen it
allows us to provide activities and
experiences that flow freely so you'll
be able to stay in those worlds and
you'll be able to experience different
things while you're in those worlds
there's a lot less loading and we've
been able to create more variety of
action than we've ever had in a Bungie
game and the amount of enemies that you
see on the screen the amount of players
that are joining you in a public event
it just gives us a lot more firepower
that we can aim at creating these
explosive social moments that will blow
your mind and bring you in contact with
players that you've never met before
how have enemies evolved like across the
board like is there been any driving
force behind making them feel fresh and
introducing new ones well we've
introduced new enemies on the cabal
front there are new enemies that you've
never fought in the ranks of the Cabal
they have incendiary attacks they've
melee attacks they have these these
reptilian quadrupeds that are their
companions and we've just made them a
little bit more ruthless and they're
going to have new ways to kick your ass
and we're going to have some surprises
up their sleeve so what are the some of
the new ways then that you can fight
back against these enemies we have three
new subclasses so the hunter the Titan
and the warlock are all going to master
new forms of combat so whether you're a
Titan who has a void shield that is both
offensive and defensive in nature
whether you're a hunter with a staff
made of pure energy
you're the combat Acrobat who's flipping
around the battlefield and you know you
know with these devastating maneuvers
and these devastating attacks or whether
you are my personal favorite the Warlock
that takes flight over the battlefield
raining down these flaming swords on
your opponent's that's the whole theme
of destiny is that in the opening act
you lose everything that makes you a
super hero
and then throughout the course of the
game you're going to master these new
forms of combat and use them to fight
back the entire weapon sandbox has also
changed up so that you have a lot more
freedom over the types of things that
you like to equip so if you want
elemental weapons if you want kinetic
weapons you can say that I want to have
a scout rifle and a hand cannon and then
there's a whole series of power weapons
that you can add to your arsenal that
are for those devastating one Gale
attacks so not only do you lose all the
all your powers but you kind of lose how
can you bring things across from the
original destiny I mean people put
hundreds of hours exact game to unlock
we do yeah legendary things but in the
opening act a player who has invested
ten hours or a thousand hours find
themselves on equal footing with all of
the new people that we hope will join
our community the weapons the gear the
armor the abilities that make you a
guardian are all forcibly removed from
you by this new enemy and we are always
providing the players of Destiny with
new challenges with new things to master
with new weapons and armor to acquire
and upgrading that character and
mastering these new abilities and really
discovering in these new sandboxes
indeed these new landscapes through the
new stories and the new enemies that
they have to fight what's the best way
of going about that we're looking at the
crucible also the crucibles completely
changed up with different ways to fight
different objectives different ways to
enjoy these activities with your friends
or with people that you meet through
matchmaking it's all 4v4 so we're always
giving them new ways to think about how
they play this game we're always looking
to surprise the community and to give
them new things that they can challenge
themselves with so some of the all modes
from destiny ones crucible have been
adapted now because it's four before yes
yeah 4v4 definitely changes the way
things work we have the Alpha at home so
I was playing control just the other
night which is you know for people who
love the crucible it's a destiny
chestnut it's the one thing that we use
to introduce people to destiny crucible
gameplay all the way back in the
original destiny alpha at e3 2014 but
now we're introducing modes like
countdown
which is what we're looking at right now
so this arc Strider is dancing around a
captured cabal explosive there's another
one right there in that base and if you
can arm those charges you can win the
round or you can eliminate the enemy
team or time runs out and the defending
team has managed to protect their turf
but having that dual objective gameplay
giving teams the ability to decide you
know which objective they're going to
prosecute or if they're going fake in
one direction and retreat and go and
attack in another direction it's created
all sorts of new tactical engagements
and scenarios and combat decisions that
the players get to make and the 4v4
loadout really puts an emphasis on every
player on that team so your strikes are
a little bit more surgical the action is
still frantic and it's still a lot of
fun to play but it's a more learnability
Rhian so players can learn from their
defeats or their victories and they can
decide how their gameplay is going to
evolve over time we saw you know the
shift in voice actors for your ghost you
know in the last game and we also saw a
pretty big shift in the tone of the game
with the first reveal not too long ago
it seems to be a sense of humor a little
bit more prevalent now can you speak to
sort of the thought behind that and like
how prevalent that is in the game
because not necessarily a bad thing but
sure that's like curious well you have
different types of characters in the
game - obviously cayde-6
sort of embodies the sense of humor that
you find in the tower you can almost
feel the other two vanguards you can
feel zeevala and iCore almost rolling
their eyes that you know this this
frontiersman this rogue that shares the
tower with them you know Cevallos sort
of the strength of the pillar he's all
business and defense and then there's
eye Cora who really embraces the
mysticism of this universe and the
curiosity about the wonders of the
traveler so we want to tell a story that
any type of player can relate to I think
the warlocks are really cool personally
every hunter loves to feel like they're
walking in Cades Six's footsteps and
then there's Zavala for the ultimate
warrior that's all about strength and
discipline so we want to have this game
be very character driven yeah we want to
tell stories that involve characters
that you care about villains that you
love to hate but really at the end of
the day it's about your own personal
story
it's about the character that you create
and the relationships that you have with
the other people that play this game how
funny can I be playing this game you can
be hilarious yeah
or you can be deadly serious and say
game faces let's get a frosty I want
some tactical chatter we keep getting
our asses kicked you're really funny but
the scoreboard isn't I'll just keep
dancing over here I guess you can just
make just keep dancing
fast when you dance emotes coming of
course we're going to have new ways for
you to express yourself as a character
new ways for you to customize your
character and to your point before
nonverbal communication is a huge part
of destiny if if we can't hear
everyone's voice in the game readily
it's always good when one player can
sort of cast a friendly wave to another
player and that could begin some sort of
social engagement that leads to a party
invite or a friend request or even a
clan invite now these people are talking
to each other and saying what do we want
to do today and how are we going to help
each other do that thing it's kinda like
that nice bit in Dark Souls if you ever
summon anyone there's always at yours
bow before you sort of take on a boss
together that is like this online
camaraderie that I really enjoy
absolutely and in the tower that is I
have one equip moat that I always equip
I don't dance I don't you know but when
I observe another Guardian I always have
sort of the Warlock bow like that's my
thank you for playing about let's talk a
little bit about the PC release because
it's I find it very interesting that
you're it's exclusive to battlenet right
we're working with our old friends and
our new partners at Blizzard to bring
destiny to to their community by working
with do you mean sort of speaking with
people maybe like the overwatch team the
world of warcraft in the diablo team to
you know make sure that everything runs
smoothly how battlenet is the system
works absolutely I mean we are talking
to everyone at Blizzard right now even
the player support team that I work with
very closely to make sure that people
who need to be informed or people who
need you know assistants connecting to
the game you know we're talking about
how we can support the Blizzard
community in the manner that they're
accustomed to and that you know we can
have that connective tissue that leads
people from their website to our website
where we talk to our players you know
we've had a very strong friendship
between our Studios you know our our
game director Luke Smith will tell
anyone who asks that use a scarab Lord
in times that he spent in World of
Warcraft were deeply inspirational to
him as a gamer and I think on a long
enough timeline as a designer we know
plenty of them play destiny
there are many an overwatch hoodie yes
to be discovered when you walk through
the halls at Bungie so we're really
interested in strengthening this
relationship they've come up to talk to
us about our game in the past and I
think we're two companies that have
taken a lot of cues of inspiration from
each other so it's really exciting for
us to be able to work with them to bring
our game to their platform could that
strengthening of relationship extend to
you know if you for example like the
latest Nexus challenges in here's the
storm right you can unlock I actually
played here as the stone so I could
unlock and you diva skin for example
good your partnership extend to in-game
customizing there's certainly no telling
where this relationship will bring us in
the future but I don't have any
announcements to make about sort of
cross game promotions or engagements at
this time what are the unique challenges
that you're facing bringing this game to
PC well we have a brand new group of
people to support we have a platform
that we have never shipped a game on at
least not right in the past 10 years
they've been we've been making console
games for a long time so we have a new
breed of player who's going to join our
community and we have new technology
that we have to optimize for right the
one thing that I'm very glad to talk
about is the fact that this isn't a port
the the PC version of destiny 2 is built
from the ground up to be awesome on that
platform and to look amazing and to play
fluidly and to support the types of
features that PC gamers expect when they
play a social cooperative game like this
I mean given the uncapped you know
ability to just have a game run as fast
as your hardware will allow and the
mouse and keyboard support would you say
the PC version is probably the best
version of destiny to that you can play
I think the best version of destiny 2 is
where you find your friends and where
you're comfortable if you are a console
gamer who wants to go and play on the PC
and you just don't have that dexterity
to be able to use a keyboard in the
mouse you can still pick up a controller
right I'll admit to you freely that's
probably how I'm going to do it my hands
have been a
my pet my hands have been enjoying those
pistol grips for a long time but I'm
going to be on the PC I'm on every
platform where people play this game so
I'm going to go in there and I'm going
to mix it up with the people in my clan
who are already building pcs to tackle
destiny - and we like to give people
different options and you should make an
informed decision as to where you want
to play destiny based on what sort of
experience you want to have or which
people will be waiting for you when you
get there
ah destiny to play one pc gonna
heartbeat good are they gonna be on a
back foot at all because they maybe they
missed the first game I certainly hope
not no we wanted to create a game that
was a great entry point for new people
who have looked at this world and could
see themselves being there and thriving
there and fighting there this is an
opportunity for anybody to join us in
the tower during its darkest moment and
to take up arms with their fellow
Guardians and fight to protect humanity
there isn't anything that we're going to
be doing in destiny - that would confuse
you if you haven't played destiny if you
have been a guardian with us over the
course of the past three years we're
certainly going to do things to
immortalize your achievements you know
sort of illustrate that legacy so both
of you upon inspection will be people
who will stand out as you know the
veterans of this community you know the
leaders of the new blood but if you've
always looked destiny and you felt like
this game's a mile down the road and
these guys are so far ahead of me that
they'll never take the time to explain
anything to me everybody finds
themselves on equal footing in the
opening act of this game and we would
love to have you join this community I
can tell you that the people that have
played this game have been a very
welcoming Bunch a seasoned Guardian who
has conquered everything the game has to
offer loves nothing more when they then
when they see a character with a low
light score and they can reach out to
that person and say can I be there the
first time you beat a raid boss sounds a
tad optimistic but I like it so
September eights is coming up September
6th number 6 yep yep we move quick moves
it up we moved up our launch date two
days so on September 6th you're going to
find destiny launching on the
PlayStation 4 and the Xbox one and then
on the PC on October
24th right what's the reason for the
delay in the PC launch well as you were
talking about the challenges you know we
want to make sure that we're building a
product that we feel is worthy of the PC
gaming community we want to make sure
that it's a product that we are excited
to ship we want to make sure that it's
the best game that the PC community can
enjoy and it's our first time serving
them in quite a long time so we're
committed to getting that right give a
good idea already about the minimum
specs you're going to need to play
destiny - I certainly don't and it's a
conversation that we will let more
informed parties lead at a later date so
I'm already sort of identifying some of
the different people at Bungie that can
help me lead that conversation with the
PC gaming community we'll introduce
those people - there would be players
and let them start talking about here's
exactly what you'll need to build in
order to join us on this adventure so
ahead of September 6 when can people get
that hands on it looks and beaches
coming up yes we have an open beta this
summer that starts on July 21st if you
want to be among the first to play
you can jump in for some early access if
you preorder destiny the game.com has
all the details for you so if you want
to go and preorder this game on the
PlayStation for the Xbox one there are
some early start dates for both of those
consoles wonderful David thank you so
much for joining us yeah thanks for
having me yeah awesome and for more on
this year's e3 coming up next we've got
Wolfenstein the new Colossus very
exciting make sure you don't go anywhere